Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on CaseFiles Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and add free, you can support case file on your preferred platform. The village of Horton is nestled on the edge
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。本剧集最初是在 CaseFiles Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上作为付费订阅者的早期奖励发布的。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前收听这些剧集并免除广告，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。霍顿村坐落在边缘
of the rolling hillsides and grassy meadows that define the Cotswolds in southwest England. In 1984, Horton was home to about 250 residents. Most of them were farming families like the backhouses, the owner-operators of a dairy farm called Widen Hill. 43-year-old patriarch Graham Backhouse lived at the property with his wife and two young children. He worked on the farm full-time with the assistance of several farmhands and herdsmen. At 300 acres, Wittenhill Farm Farmers, was a decent size for a non-industrial operation.
连绵起伏的丘陵和草地，这些构成了英格兰西南部科茨沃尔德的特色。1984年，霍顿约有250名居民。他们大多数是像巴克豪斯一家那样的农户，他们是名为“威登山”奶牛场的经营者。43岁的户主格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯与妻子及两个年幼的孩子住在这处房产里。他在几名农场工人和牧民的协助下全职经营农场。威登山农场占地300英亩，对于非工业化经营来说，规模相当不错。
To walk the entirety of the farm's perimeter took at least 45 minutes. On Tuesday, April 3, 1984, one of the farmhands was conducting an inspection of Widenhill's fence line when he came across a disturbing sight. Impaled on a fence post was a freshly decapitated sheep's head. Pinned beneath it was a handwritten note containing two words. You next. When Whittenhill's owner Graham Backhouse was informed about the gruesome discovery, he immediately knew that the message was directed at him.
走完农场一圈至少需要45分钟。1984年4月3日星期二，一名农场工人在检查威登山围栏线时，看到了令人不安的一幕。一根围栏柱上插着一颗刚被砍下的羊头。下面别着一张手写的纸条，上面写着两个词：“下一个是你”。当威登山的主人格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯得知这一可怕的发现时，他立刻意识到这条信息是针对他的。
Over the last few weeks, someone had made it clear they had a vendetta against Graham. It started in mid-March. Graham was sorting through the farm's mail when a handwritten letter caught his eye. It was addressed to Graham specifically and read. At last I have found you. You have ruined my sister's life. Now you must pay. The sender didn't elaborate any further, nor did they reveal their identity.
在过去几周里，有人明确表示对格雷厄姆怀恨在心。这一切始于3月中旬。格雷厄姆在整理农场邮件时，一封手写信引起了他的注意。信是专门写给格雷厄姆的，上面写着：“终于找到你了。你毁了我妹妹的生活。现在你必须付出代价。”寄信人没有再多做解释，也没有透露自己的身份。
Graham wasn't overly concerned about the letter, as he had no idea what it could be alluding to. He threw it in the bin. Days later, the farmhouse phone rang. Graham answered the call. on the other line was a man whose voice he didn't recognize. It sounded like he was using a fake Irish or Scottish accent. The caller threatened to blow Graham's balls off before hanging up. The following week, Graham received another mysterious phone call.
格雷厄姆并没有太在意这封信，因为他不知道这指的是什么。他把它扔进了垃圾桶。几天后，农舍的电话响了。格雷厄姆接了电话。电话那头是一个他听不出来的男人的声音。听起来他好像在用假装的爱尔兰或苏格兰口音。打电话的人威胁要炸掉格雷厄姆的睾丸，然后挂断了电话。接下来的一周，格雷厄姆又接到了一个神秘电话。
As soon as he heard the male voice, he could tell it was the same anonymous caller. This time, the man threatened Graham's family. referring to his wife, 37-year-old Margaret, and their children, 8-year-old Harry and 6-year-old Sophie, by name. Graham told Margaret about the letter and phone calls, but otherwise kept the harassment to himself. After the discovery of the slaughtered sheep and the explicit death threat left on their fence in April, Graham could no longer dismiss the danger. He contacted the police. When officers arrived at Witten Hill, neither Graham nor Margaret could offer any explanation as to why they had been targeted.
他一听到那个男人的声音，就知道是同一个匿名来电者。这一次，那个人威胁了格雷厄姆的家人，指名道姓地提到了他37岁的妻子玛格丽特，以及他们8岁的儿子哈里和6岁的女儿索菲。格雷厄姆告诉了玛格丽特关于信件和电话的事，但除此之外，他没有向其他人透露这些骚扰。在4月份发现被屠宰的羊和围栏上留下的明确死亡威胁后，格雷厄姆再也无法忽视这种危险。他联系了警察。当警察到达威登山时，格雷厄姆和玛格丽特都无法解释他们为何成为目标。
With no immediate leads, police connected a recording device to the farm's phone line. Should the mystery man call again, police would at least have a recording of his threats. In the meantime, investigators searched for anyone who might hold a grudge against Graham backhouse. They discovered he had a blemish to his name. Just over ten years earlier, Graham and his father, Bill Backhouse, were convicted of stealing three young cows belonging to a neighbouring farmer. The judge described the theft as disgraceful and dishonorable. The backhouse men were each fined £600,
由于没有直接线索，警方在农场的电话线上连接了录音设备。如果那个神秘人再次打来电话，警方至少能录下他的威胁。与此同时，调查人员寻找任何可能对格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯怀恨在心的人。他们发现他的名声有污点。就在十多年前，格雷厄姆和他的父亲比尔·巴克豪斯因偷窃邻近农场主的三头小牛而被定罪。法官称这次盗窃是可耻和不光彩的。巴克豪斯父子每人被罚款600英镑，
the equivalent of roughly £10,000 in today's money. However, police quickly dismissed the disgruntled foe. farmer as a potential suspect in the recent harassment. He passed away in 1977. After Graham's conviction for theft, he spent the next decade rebuilding his reputation in Horton. Police inquiries revealed that the backhouses were considered a typical happy farming family who were well respected around town. Six days after the discovery of the sheep's head, on the morning of Monday, April 9, Graham walked to the farm's mailbox. Inside was a handwritten envelope addressed only to Backhouse.
相当于今天大约1万英镑。然而，警方很快排除了这位心怀不满的农场主作为近期骚扰案的潜在嫌疑人。他在1977年去世了。格雷厄姆因盗窃罪被定罪后，他在接下来的十年里在霍顿重建了自己的声誉。警方调查显示，巴克豪斯一家被认为是典型的幸福农户，在镇上很受尊敬。在发现羊头六天后，即4月9日星期一早上，格雷厄姆走到农场的邮箱前。里面有一个手写的信封，只写着“巴克豪斯收”。
Graham immediately recognized the distinctive handwriting. Inside was a letter that read, Came twice last week, but the pigs were about. There was no name or signature at the bottom, only the words, See you soon. Later that morning, Margaret Backhouse needed. to drive into town to pick up supplies from the vat. Graham reminded Margaret that her fiat was playing up, so she should take his Volvo instead. Margaret entered the barn next to the farmhouse
格雷厄姆立刻认出了那独特的笔迹。里面是一封信，写着：“上周来了两次，但猪都在附近。”底部没有名字或签名，只有“回头见”三个字。那天晚些时候，玛格丽特·巴克豪斯需要开车进城去买补给品。格雷厄姆提醒玛格丽特她的菲亚特车出了毛病，所以她应该开他的沃尔沃。玛格丽特走进农舍旁边的谷仓，
where her husband kept his vehicle. She got into the driver's seat and turned the key in the ignition. A great force of energy exploded from underneath the vehicle, tearing a hole through the floor and ripping the driver's seat in half. There was blood everywhere. The tissue on Margaret's thighs and buttocks had been blown to shreds. She opened the car door and fell onto the ground, managing to crawl her way out of the barn. Michael Cleverly was driving the local school bus past Widenhill Farm
她丈夫把车停在那里。她坐进驾驶座，转动点火钥匙。一股巨大的能量从车底爆炸开来，在地板上炸开一个洞，并将驾驶座撕成两半。到处都是血。玛格丽特大腿和臀部的组织被炸得粉碎。她打开车门倒在地上，设法爬出了谷仓。迈克尔·克莱弗利当时正开着当地的校车经过威登山农场，
when he noticed Margaret Backhouse lying on the driveway, desperately waving one hand in the air. Michael stopped his bus and dashed to Margaret's side. Schoolgirl Susan Wilkie also jumped off the bus. Susan lived on a nearby farm and knew the backhouses. She ran through Whitten Hill, shouting, Graham, Margaret's had an accident. Graham emerged from the milking shed out of earshot of the blast.
当他注意到玛格丽特·巴克豪斯躺在车道上，绝望地挥动着一只手。迈克尔停下校车，冲到玛格丽特身边。女学生苏珊·威尔基也跳下车。苏珊住在附近的一个农场，认识巴克豪斯一家。她跑过威登山，大喊：“格雷厄姆，玛格丽特出事了。”格雷厄姆从挤奶棚里出来，没听到爆炸声。
When he saw Margaret's injuries, he turned pale and began shaking. He ran into the farmhouse and called an ambulance, before re-emerging with a blanket that he lay over Margaret. Through pain and shock, Margaret told Graham not to move or touch her. Margaret was taken to hospital with severe injuries to her buttocks, thigh and lower back. Surgeons spent seven hours removing deeply embedded shrapnel and did their best to salvage the remaining tissue. Meanwhile, police sealed off Widenhill. An army bomb disposal unit was called in to clear the scene.
当他看到玛格丽特的伤势时，他脸色苍白，开始颤抖。他跑进农舍叫了救护车，然后拿着一条毯子出来盖在玛格丽特身上。在痛苦和震惊中，玛格丽特告诉格雷厄姆不要移动或触碰她。玛格丽特被送往医院，臀部、大腿和下背部受了重伤。外科医生花了七个小时取出深埋的弹片，并尽最大努力挽救剩余的组织。与此同时，警方封锁了威登山。军方拆弹小组被召集来清理现场。
Once it was deemed safe, police explosive experts processed the wreckage of the Volvo. Little evidence of the explosion was visible from the car's exterior. Only the roof was slightly dented and a window pane cracked. However, when police opened the doors, there was practically nothing left of the driver's side floor or seat. Specialists determined that a homemade pipe bomb had been placed under the car beneath the driver's seat. The bomb was made using a 10 centimetre long piece of steel scuffolding pipe, which had been screwed onto a cast iron collar. The pipe had been packed with 4,500 lead pellets and gunpowder from up to 12 shotgun cartridges. Margaret Backhouse wouldn't have noticed anything out of the ordinary.
一旦被认为安全，警方爆炸物专家处理了沃尔沃的残骸。从车外几乎看不到爆炸的痕迹。只有车顶稍微凹陷，一块窗玻璃破裂。然而，当警察打开车门时，驾驶座一侧的地板或座椅几乎荡然无存。专家确定，一个自制的管状炸弹被放置在车内驾驶座下方。炸弹是用一段10厘米长的钢脚手架管制成的，管子拧在一个铸铁套环上。管子里装满了4500颗铅弹和多达12个猎枪弹壳里的火药。玛格丽特·巴克豪斯本不会注意到任何异常。
The bomb had been wired to the aground. ignition and the fuse of a heating element that warmed up the driver's seat, with the wiring concealed from view. As soon as Margaret turned to the Volvo's ignition, the bomb exploded. In any other car, the explosion would have likely been fatal. However, the backhouse's Volvo was a particular model that had thinner, more flexible floor panels and a solid, heavy seat that was bolted to the frame. The floor panels absorbed the vast majority of the floor panels absorbed the vast majority of the bomb's impact, and the seat's sturdy construction acted like a safety cage. These features had saved Margaret's life.
炸弹与点火装置以及加热驾驶座的加热元件的保险丝相连，线路被隐藏起来。玛格丽特一转动沃尔沃的点火开关，炸弹就爆炸了。在任何其他汽车上，这次爆炸都可能是致命的。然而，巴克豪斯家的沃尔沃是一款特殊的车型，其地板面板更薄、更灵活，座椅坚固且沉重，并用螺栓固定在框架上。地板面板吸收了炸弹绝大部分的冲击力，座椅坚固的结构起到了安全笼的作用。这些特点救了玛格丽特的命。
One detective described to the bomb to the Bristol Evening Post as, a diabolical device placed by someone who has no consideration for human life. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. Margaret Backhouse was a fundraiser and local treasurer for the Save the Children charity. It seemed highly unlikely that she'd run afoul of anyone in town.
一位侦探向《布里斯托尔晚报》描述这个炸弹为：“一个由对人类生命毫无顾忌的人放置的恶魔装置。”Case file稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Case File继续提供高质量的内容。玛格丽特·巴克豪斯是“救助儿童会”慈善机构的筹款人和当地财务主管。她似乎不太可能在镇上得罪任何人。
Given that Graham Backhouse was the one who usually drove the Volvo, police believed that he had been the intended target of the car bomb. Fearing for their safety, Graham and Margaret's children were sent to stay with their grandmother. Graham returned to Whitten Hill, with the 24-hour police presence established to guard against any further attacks. While Margaret recovered in hospital, Graham attended the police station for an interview. With the harasser delivering on their threats, Graham knew it was time to talk. Contrary to what he'd previously told detectives, Graham conceded there could be someone in the village who held a grudge against him.
鉴于格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯通常是开沃尔沃的人，警方认为他才是汽车炸弹的预定目标。出于安全考虑，格雷厄姆和玛格丽特的孩子们被送去和祖母住在一起。格雷厄姆回到了威登山，警方建立了24小时警力以防范任何进一步的袭击。当玛格丽特在医院康复时，格雷厄姆前往警察局接受询问。随着骚扰者兑现了他们的威胁，格雷厄姆知道是时候谈谈了。与他之前告诉侦探的情况相反，格雷厄姆承认村里可能有人对他怀恨在心。
He admitted he was having a boundary dispute with one of his neighbours. Detectives noted this information, but deemed it an unlikely motive. It was much more likely that the person responsible for the harassment and bomb held a more personal grievance against Graham. With a little further prodding, Graham made another confession. During the 12 years he'd been married to Margaret, he'd had multiple affairs. In the months leading up to the car bomb, he'd had a drunken sexual encounter with a woman named Caroline Hodkinson. Caroline was the wife of Graham's good friend, David, who had been the best man at Graham and Margaret's wedding.
他承认自己与其中一位邻居有边界纠纷。侦探们记录了这一信息，但认为这不太可能是动机。更有可能的是，对骚扰和炸弹负责的人对格雷厄姆怀有更私人的怨恨。在进一步的追问下，格雷厄姆又做了一次坦白。在他与玛格丽特结婚的12年里，他有过多次婚外情。在汽车炸弹事件发生前的几个月里，他与一个名叫卡罗琳·霍金森的女人有过一次酒后性行为。卡罗琳是格雷厄姆的好友大卫的妻子，大卫曾是格雷厄姆和玛格丽特婚礼上的伴郎。
Graham admitted he'd also been having occasional sex with the 24-year-old shepherdess named Gillian Lipiat. Gillian lived on her family's farm on the edge of Horton, which overlooked Witten Hill. According to Graham, the two had been casually sleeping together for the past nine years. Graham denied having romantic feelings towards Gillian, but said he was flattered by the attention from someone half his age. Graham Backhouser's infidelity confession didn't come as a complete surprise to police. Horton was a small place.
格雷厄姆承认他还曾与一位名叫吉莉安·利皮亚特的24岁牧羊女偶尔发生性关系。吉莉安住在霍顿边缘她家的农场里，可以俯瞰威登山。据格雷厄姆说，两人在过去九年里一直随意地发生性关系。格雷厄姆否认对吉莉安有浪漫感情，但表示被一个比自己小一半的人关注感到受宠若惊。格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯的通奸坦白并没有让警方感到完全意外。霍顿是个小地方。
Rumors had already been circulating around town, with one local telling the Sunday Times, We all know each other very well, some of us too well. A lover's revenge quickly rose to the top of the list for potential motives. Detectives considered whether Jillie Julian Lippiac could be behind the bomb and harassment, or maybe someone in the Lippeat family was upset about Graham's sexual interest in Gillian.
镇上已经流传着谣言，一位当地人告诉《星期日泰晤士报》：“我们彼此都很了解，有些人了解得太透彻了。”情人的报复很快成为潜在动机名单的首位。侦探们考虑了吉莉安·利皮亚特是否是炸弹和骚扰事件的幕后黑手，或者利皮亚特家族中是否有人对格雷厄姆对吉莉安的性兴趣感到不满。
Her father was one of the best and most accomplished cereal growers in the business and a popular personality in Horton. He and his family had been close friends with the backhouses for more than a decade. When questioned by police, the members of the Lippeat family all denied responsibility for the car bomb. As for the suggestion that she was having a sexual relationship with Graham Backhouse, Gillian said it was a complete figment of Graham's imagination. She called it extremely distasteful and denied any such contact,
她的父亲是业内最出色、最有成就的谷物种植者之一，也是霍顿的一位受欢迎的人物。他和他的家人与巴克豪斯一家是十多年的密友。当被警方询问时，利皮亚特家族的成员都否认对汽车炸弹负责。至于她与格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯有性关系的说法，吉莉安说这完全是格雷厄姆的想象。她称其极其令人反感，并否认有任何此类接触，
saying her interactions with Graham over the years had been very limited. He occasionally helped her sheer sheep or euthanise her injured animals, but nothing sexual had ever occurred between them. Unsure what to make of this, police turned their attention to the other woman Graham had admitted to being intimate with, Caroline Hodkinson. They discovered that Caroline's husband, David, was an electrical engineer who had previously worked with explosives. He'd also conducted repairs on Graham's Volvo in the past. Police arrived at the Hodgkinson House to question the couple, only to find that David was in Spain and had been there since before this. explosion. However, David's absence from the area on the day of the bomb didn't necessarily rule him
说她多年来与格雷厄姆的互动非常有限。他偶尔帮她剪羊毛或安乐死受伤的动物，但他们之间从未发生过任何性行为。警方不确定该如何处理这些信息，便将注意力转向了格雷厄姆承认与之亲密的另一个女人——卡罗琳·霍金森。他们发现卡罗琳的丈夫大卫是一名电气工程师，曾从事过爆炸物工作。他过去也曾修理过格雷厄姆的沃尔沃。警察到达霍金森家询问这对夫妇，却发现大卫在西班牙，而且自爆炸发生前就一直在那里。然而，大卫在爆炸当天不在该地区并不一定能排除他
out as a suspect. As soon as he returned home, he was promptly placed under arrest. David Hodkinson was held for questioning for two days, but police couldn't find any evidence to connect him to the bomb and they had no choice but to release him. Nine days after the explosion, Graham Backhouse insisted he no longer wanted the 24-hour police presence at the farmhouse. He wanted the bomber to, quote, have another go while Margaret was still in hospital and the kids were safely staying elsewhere. It seemed to be the only way to identify the person responsible, and Graham believed the bomber was unlikely to strike while the police were there. Investigators reluctantly agreed, but as a precaution, they installed a panic button onto the farmhouse phone providing a direct
作为嫌疑人。他一回到家，就立即被捕。大卫·霍金森被拘留审问了两天，但警方找不到任何证据将他与炸弹联系起来，他们别无选择，只能释放他。爆炸发生九天后，格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯坚持说他不再需要农舍的24小时警力。他想让炸弹客“再试一次”，而玛格丽特还在医院，孩子们也安全地待在别处。这似乎是识别责任人的唯一方法，格雷厄姆认为炸弹客不太可能在有警察在场时发动袭击。调查人员勉强同意了，但作为预防措施，他们在农舍电话上安装了一个紧急按钮，提供直接
connection to the police. Weeks passed without incident. Having reached a dead end with the lover's revenge theory, police looked into the land dispute Graham Backhouse claimed to be having with his neighbour, Colin Bedale Taylor. The 63-year-old former army officer lived in a converted cottage known as the gatehouse. The Cottages driveway ran alongside the back fields of Wittenhill Farm. According to Graham, Colin had been denying him his legal right to use the driveway so that he could access the fields.
连接到警察局。几周过去了，没有发生任何事件。在“情人报复”理论陷入死胡同后，警方调查了格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯声称与邻居科林·比代尔-泰勒之间存在的土地纠纷。这位63岁的前陆军军官住在一间名为“门房”的改建小屋里。小屋的车道沿着威登山农场的后田延伸。据格雷厄姆说，科林一直拒绝他使用车道的合法权利，以便他进入田地。
On Monday, April 30, three weeks after the bombing, detectives visited the home of Colomberdale Taylor and his wife, also named Margaret. The couple had lived in the gatehouse for over 20 years where they raised their fortune. children. When questioned about the boundary dispute, Colin denied having any conflict with Graham or anyone else involved with Whittenhill. He claimed he and Margaret barely knew the backhouses. Colin was later excused so that the detectives could speak candidly with his wife. They then asked her about Colin's criminal convictions. Margaret was blindsided. She had no idea what the detectives were talking about. They explained that Colin had been convicted twice for shoplifting. After recovering from her shock, Margaret explained that the last few years had been very difficult,
4月30日星期一，即爆炸发生三周后，侦探们拜访了科林·比代尔-泰勒和他同样名为玛格丽特的妻子的家。这对夫妇在门房住了20多年，在那里抚养了他们的孩子。当被问及边界纠纷时，科林否认与格雷厄姆或任何与威登山有关的人有任何冲突。他声称他和玛格丽特几乎不认识巴克豪斯一家。科林随后被请走，以便侦探们能与他的妻子坦诚交谈。他们随后询问了科林的前科。玛格丽特感到措手不及。她根本不知道侦探们在说什么。他们解释说科林曾因入店行窃被定罪两次。在从震惊中恢复过来后，玛格丽特解释说过去几年非常困难，
especially for Colin. In 1981, Colin lost his job and fell into depression. The following year, Colin and Margaret's youngest son, 19-year-old Digby, was killed in a car accident. The driver of the car was Digby's friend, Denzel Woolacott. Denzel survived the crash and was charged with reckless driving, but later cleared of any criminal liability. He was eventually employed by Graham Backhouse to do odd jobs at Whitten Hill. Colin's mental health suffered further each time he crossed paths with Denzel. Despite these hardships, Margaret assured the detectives that Colin had just started seeing a psychiatrist and was getting the help he needed. During this discussion, Colin busied himself in his workshop. As a way to pass time, he had taken to restoring old furniture
尤其是对科林来说。1981年，科林失业并陷入抑郁。第二年，科林和玛格丽特最小的儿子，19岁的迪格比，在车祸中丧生。车祸的司机是迪格比的朋友丹泽尔·伍拉科特。丹泽尔在车祸中幸存，被控鲁莽驾驶，但后来被免除了任何刑事责任。他最终被格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯雇佣在威登山做零工。每次科林与丹泽尔相遇，他的心理健康状况都会进一步恶化。尽管有这些困难，玛格丽特向侦探们保证，科林刚开始看精神科医生，并得到了他需要的帮助。在这次讨论中，科林在车间里忙碌着。为了打发时间，他开始修复旧家具
for people in the village. Eventually, Colin put his tools down and popped his head inside the house. Margaret was still speaking with the detectives. Colin interrupted briefly to tell his wife that he was going to the backhouses, but offered no explanation as to why. Neither she nor the detectives questioned it. It was around sunset as Colin Bedale-Taylor walked the short distance to Whittenhill Farm. Outside, the place was quiet. The workers had left for the day, and there were no longer any police guarding the property. Lights were on inside the farmhouse as Colin knocked on the front door. Ten minutes later, the sound of sirens pierced the air. Eight police cars and an ambulance sped up Horton Hill.
为村里的人。最终，科林放下工具，把头探进屋里。玛格丽特还在和侦探们说话。科林简短地打断了谈话，告诉妻子他要去巴克豪斯家，但没有解释原因。她和侦探们都没有质疑。大约在日落时分，科林·比代尔-泰勒步行前往威登山农场。外面很安静。工人们已经下班了，农场也不再有警察守卫。当科林敲前门时，农舍里亮着灯。十分钟后，警笛声划破了空气。八辆警车和一辆救护车疾驰上霍顿山。
Someone had raised the panic alarm at Whitten Hill. Officers entered the farmhouse to a confronting sight. Graham Backhouse was standing in the hallway dripping with blood. The left side of his face had been slashed from ear to lip. A long, deep wound ran from his left shoulder across. cross to his right hip. Beside him was a 12-gauge shotgun. Colin Bedale Taylor
有人在威登山按下了紧急警报。警察进入农舍，看到了令人震惊的一幕。格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯站在走廊里，浑身是血。他左脸从耳朵到嘴唇被划开。一道又长又深的伤口从他的左肩一直延伸到右臀部。他身边是一把12号口径猎枪。科林·比代尔-泰勒
laid dead on the hallway floor. He had taken two shotgun blasts to the chest. In his right hand was a Stanley knife. Graham was swiftly taken to hospital where he underwent surgery to close his wounds. The injury to his face alone required 50 stitches. Police kept a guard over both his room and Margaret's, while the Backhous's children fled Horton with their grandparents to ensure their safety.
躺在走廊地板上死了。他的胸部中了两次猎枪射击。他右手拿着一把斯坦利美工刀。格雷厄姆被迅速送往医院，在那里他接受了手术以缝合伤口。仅脸上的伤口就需要50针。警方在他的房间和玛格丽特的房间外都派了守卫，而巴克豪斯的孩子们则与祖父母逃离了霍顿以确保安全。
When Graham was able to speak, police interviewed him at his bedside. He told them that Colin Bedale Taylor had knocked on the farmhouse door. Graham invited him inside and the two sat down at the kitchen table. At first, Colin inquired about Margaret's. its recovery, then asked whether Graham had any old furniture that needed repair. But the mood suddenly shifted. Colin told Graham that God had sent him. Caught off guard by his comment, Graham laughed, which angered Colin. He told Graham it was blasphemous to laugh at God and that Graham would pay for it. Colin's mood then quickly shifted again. He became quiet and
当格雷厄姆能够说话时，警方在床边采访了他。他告诉他们，科林·比代尔-泰勒敲了农舍的门。格雷厄姆请他进去，两人坐在厨房桌旁。起初，科林询问了玛格丽特的康复情况，然后问格雷厄姆是否有需要修理的旧家具。但气氛突然变了。科林告诉格雷厄姆，是上帝派他来的。格雷厄姆被他的话弄得措手不及，笑了起来，这激怒了科林。他告诉格雷厄姆，嘲笑上帝是亵渎神灵，格雷厄姆会为此付出代价。科林的脾气随后又迅速转变。他变得安静且
calm, asking, why did you kill my son? Graham told Colin that he didn't, reminding him that Digby had died in a car accident. It was then that Colin produced a Stanley knife and lunged at Graham, shouting that he was doing God's work. Colin slashed Graham across the face and chest. In shock and bleeding heavily, Graham managed to flee into the hallway. He grabbed. He grabbed. grabbed the 12-gate shotgun that had been leaning on the stairs and spun around to face his attacker. Graham shouted for Colin to stop, warning that he would shoot. But Colin kept moving forward, the Stanley knife raised. Graham had no choice. He fired two shots and Colin fell to the floor. Two days after the shooting, Graham Backhouse was discharged from hospital. He spent a few days
冷静，问道：“你为什么要杀我儿子？”格雷厄姆告诉科林他没有，提醒他迪格比死于车祸。就在那时，科林掏出一把斯坦利美工刀向格雷厄姆扑去，大喊他是在替天行道。科林划伤了格雷厄姆的脸和胸部。在震惊和大量出血的情况下，格雷厄姆设法逃进走廊。他抓住了靠在楼梯上的12号口径猎枪，转身面对袭击者。格雷厄姆大喊让科林停下，警告他会开枪。但科林继续向前，举着斯坦利美工刀。格雷厄姆别无选择。他开了两枪，科林倒在地上。枪击事件发生两天后，格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯出院了。他花了几天时间
with his mother before being permitted to return to Widen Hill. Later that week, his wife Margaret was also discharged. She had recovered from the bomb blast but still required crutches to move around. Margaret traveled directly to her parents' home in the West Midlands to be reunited with her children. With Colin Bedale-Taylor dead after being identified as the backhouse's harasser, it seemed to be an open and shut case. But investigators weren't so sure. When Graham Backhouse had been recovering from his injuries,
和母亲在一起，然后被允许回到威登山。那周晚些时候，他的妻子玛格丽特也出院了。她从炸弹爆炸中恢复过来，但仍需要拐杖才能走动。玛格丽特直接前往她父母在西米德兰兹的家，与孩子们团聚。随着科林·比代尔-泰勒在被确认为巴克豪斯家的骚扰者后死亡，这似乎是一个结案的案件。但调查人员并不确定。当格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯从伤势中恢复时，
police conducted a grid search of Columbadale-Taylor's property. As one officer was scanning the front garden, a flash of metal in the grass caught his eye. Upon closer inspection, the officer realized it was a piece of scuff-holding pipe. It looked remarkably similar to the one used in the Backhouser's car bomb. The two pipes were examined under microscope. When compared, markings caused by a hacksaw on the end of each matched up. This provided a direct link between Columbert Dale Taylor and the bomb. But there was something about the pipe's location that didn't
警方对科林·比代尔-泰勒的房产进行了网格搜索。当一名警官扫描前花园时，草丛中闪过的一道金属光芒引起了他的注意。经过仔细检查，警官意识到那是一段脚手架管。它看起来与巴克豪斯家汽车炸弹中使用的那段非常相似。两段管子在显微镜下进行了检查。比较时，每段管子末端的钢锯痕迹吻合。这提供了科林·比代尔-泰勒与炸弹之间的直接联系。但管子的位置有些不对劲，
seem right. The grass underneath it hadn't withered and it was barely flattened by the weight of the pipe. It appeared that the pipe had only been in the grass for a day or two. This raised the question, why would Colin relocate the pipe three weeks after the bomb, and why leave it in a place where it could be so easily found? Police began to consider the possibility that Colin Bidale-Taylor hadn't touched the pipe at all. He'd been framed. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
似乎不对。下面的草没有枯萎，而且几乎没有被管子的重量压平。看起来管子在草丛里只待了一两天。这引发了一个问题：为什么科林要在炸弹爆炸三周后移动管子，又为什么要把它留在这么容易被发现的地方？警方开始考虑科林·比代尔-泰勒根本没碰过管子的可能性。他是被陷害的。Case file稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。
By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. Following the explosion that nearly killed Margaret Backhouse, one of the Widenhill farmhands had told police he recalled hearing noises coming from an outbuilding a few days before the bomb went off. At the time, the farmhand thought he was the only person on the premises. He went to investigate the noise, only to find Graham Backhouse cutting a length of pipe with a hacksaw.
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Case File继续提供高质量的内容。在差点炸死玛格丽特·巴克豪斯的爆炸发生后，威登山的一名农场工人告诉警方，他记得在炸弹爆炸前几天听到附属建筑里有声音。当时，这名农场工人以为他是现场唯一的人。他去调查声音，却发现格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯正在用钢锯切割一段管子。
Schoolgirl Susan Wilkie had been one of the first on the scene after the car bomb went off. Susan told detectives that when she ran to tell Graham that Margaret had been injured, she never mentioned anything about a bomb or an explosion. Graham couldn't have heard the explosion from the milking shed, and he didn't enter the barn at the time. Yet, when he phoned for the ambulance, he specifically told the operator that his wife had been injured in an explosion. The person who installed the car bomb had to be familiar with the particular model of Volvo. They would have also needed extended access to the vehicle in order to fit the device. Graham Backhouse ticked both of these boxes. Throughout their
女学生苏珊·威尔基是汽车炸弹爆炸后第一批到达现场的人之一。苏珊告诉侦探，当她跑去告诉格雷厄姆玛格丽特受伤时，她从未提到过炸弹或爆炸。格雷厄姆不可能在挤奶棚听到爆炸声，而且他当时并没有进入谷仓。然而，当他打电话叫救护车时，他明确告诉接线员他的妻子在爆炸中受伤了。安装汽车炸弹的人必须熟悉沃尔沃的特定车型。他们还需要对车辆有长时间的接触才能安装该装置。格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯符合这两个条件。在他们的
investigations, detectives had remained open to the possibility that Graham was involved in the attack. But there was no physical evidence linking him to the crime, and by all accounts, Graham and Margaret had a happy and loving relationship. It seemed much more likely that someone else was responsible, and as such they directed their inquiries elsewhere. After Columbertale Taylor's death, several more questions were raised. Graham told officers that Colin had slashed him with the Stanley knife while the two were in the kitchen. But when forensic investigators analysed the crime scene, they found no cast-off blood spatter on the walls, floor or furniture, as would be expected.
调查过程中，侦探们一直对格雷厄姆参与袭击的可能性持开放态度。但没有实物证据将他与犯罪联系起来，而且据所有人的说法，格雷厄姆和玛格丽特有着幸福而充满爱的关系。似乎更有可能是其他人负责，因此他们将调查转向了别处。在科林·比代尔-泰勒死后，又提出了几个问题。格雷厄姆告诉警察，科林在厨房时用斯坦利美工刀划伤了他。但当法医调查员分析犯罪现场时，他们发现墙壁、地板或家具上没有预期的喷溅血迹。
Instead, round drops of blood were grouped together in several locations on the kitchen floor. Some of the blood drops were found underneath the upturned kitchen chairs. while smears of blood were also found on the backrest of each chair. After being injured, Graham claimed to have fled the kitchen and stumbled into the hallway to grab his shotgun. However, there was no trail of blood leading between these two locations and not a drop of blood on the shotgun. Droplets of blood matching Graham's blood type
相反，圆形的血滴聚集在厨房地板上的几个位置。一些血滴是在翻倒的厨房椅子下发现的，而每把椅子的靠背上也发现了血迹。受伤后，格雷厄姆声称逃离厨房并跌跌撞撞地走进走廊去拿他的猎枪。然而，这两个位置之间没有血迹，猎枪上也没有一滴血。与格雷厄姆血型匹配的血滴
were also found on Colin's body. With the blood evidence raising more questions than answers, answers, investigators turned to the threatening letters that Graham Backhouse had received. A handwriting expert compared the notes to a sample of Colomberdale-Taylor's handwriting. The lettering was completely different. The notes were then compared to the handwriting of Graham Backhouse. This time, the similarities were significant. On the death thread accompanying the sheep's head, the words, U.N. Next had been, scrolled on a piece of lined notebook paper.
也在科林的尸体上被发现。随着血液证据引发的问题多于答案，调查人员转向了格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯收到的威胁信。笔迹专家将这些便条与科林·比代尔-泰勒的笔迹样本进行了比较。字体完全不同。这些便条随后与格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯的笔迹进行了比较。这一次，相似之处非常显著。在羊头随附的死亡威胁上，“U.N. Next”这些词是用带横线的笔记本纸写成的。
Some of the sheep's blood had seeped into the paper, but analysts were still able to make out an imprint on the back of the page. It was a complex spiral-shaped doodle. When police were collecting evidence from the Widenhill Farmhouse after Column was shot, they seized a small lined notebook from Graham's study. The paper was of a similar size to the U-next note. Investigators flicked through the pages until something caught their eye. Drawn in pen was the exact same spiral-shaped doodle.
一些羊血渗进了纸里，但分析人员仍然能够辨认出页面背后的压痕。那是一个复杂的螺旋形涂鸦。当警察在科林被枪杀后从威登山农舍收集证据时，他们从格雷厄姆的书房里查获了一个带横线的小笔记本。纸张的大小与“U-next”便条相似。调查人员翻阅页面，直到有什么东西引起了他们的注意。用笔画着完全相同的螺旋形涂鸦。
With this evidence emerging, investigators grew confident that Graham Backhouse had planted the bomb with the intention of killing his wife. Failing to do so, he framed Columbertale Taylor for the crime. The question was, why? Graham's financial records revealed that he had inherited Whittenhill Farm from his father, Bill, in 1979. At the time, the farm was a profitable business, renowned for producing champion dairy cows. In an attempt to increase the farm's revenue, Graham tried his hand at growing cereal crops on some of the excess land. But the crops were quickly ravaged by the plant disease known as take-all and the vener. Fischer failed. Unlike his father, Graham was not an astute businessman. Over the next four years,
随着这些证据的出现，调查人员确信格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯安放炸弹的目的是杀死他的妻子。未能得逞后，他陷害科林·比代尔-泰勒犯下了罪行。问题是，为什么？格雷厄姆的财务记录显示，他于1979年从父亲比尔那里继承了威登山农场。当时，该农场是一项盈利的业务，以生产冠军奶牛而闻名。为了增加农场收入，格雷厄姆尝试在一些多余的土地上种植谷物作物。但作物很快被一种称为“全蚀病”的植物病害摧毁，冒险失败了。与他父亲不同，格雷厄姆不是一个精明的商人。在接下来的四年里，
he mismanaged the dairy farm and it began to lose money. By the end of 1983, the farm was 70,000 pounds in debt. Graham had run it into the ground. A search of the Baccauser's personal records revealed that Graham and Margaret had recently applied to double the payout on their life insurance policies. In the event of Margaret's death, Graham stood to receive 100,000 pounds. Only days after the application was made, the so-called Campaign of Threats against Graham began. On Thursday, April 5, 1984, the new life insurance policies were approved. Four days later, Margaret unwittingly detonated the car bomb. Having failed in his plot to kill his wife,
他管理不善，奶牛场开始亏损。到1983年底，农场负债7万英镑。格雷厄姆把它搞垮了。对巴克豪斯个人记录的搜索显示，格雷厄姆和玛格丽特最近申请将他们的人寿保险单赔付额翻倍。如果玛格丽特死亡，格雷厄姆将获得10万英镑。申请提出仅几天后，所谓的针对格雷厄姆的“威胁运动”就开始了。1984年4月5日星期四，新的人寿保险单获得批准。四天后，玛格丽特在不知情的情况下引爆了汽车炸弹。在谋杀妻子的阴谋失败后，
investigators believed that Graham Backhouse was faced with two problems. The first was that he still needed to pay off his crippling debt. Inquiries with his insurance company revealed that in the week after the explosion, Graham submitted a claim on Margaret's behalf. Given that she'd survived, they weren't entitled to the full 100,000 pounds, but Margaret's serious injuries would have warranted at least some amount of compensation. Graham's second larger problem was that he needed to deflect suspicion away from himself. In addition to coming clean about his legitimate infidelities, he fabricated an affair with the Gillian Lipiat.
调查人员认为格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯面临两个问题。第一个是他仍然需要偿还沉重的债务。对保险公司的调查显示，在爆炸发生后的那一周，格雷厄姆代表玛格丽特提交了索赔。鉴于她幸存下来，他们无权获得全部10万英镑，但玛格丽特的严重伤势至少应该获得一定数额的赔偿。格雷厄姆的第二个更大的问题是他需要转移对自己身上的怀疑。除了坦白他合法的婚外情外，他还捏造了与吉莉安·利皮亚特的恋情。
He also concocted a boundary dispute with Colin Bedale Taylor. These admissions opened up several lines of investigations. all painting Graham as a target for someone's grievance. Police believed that Graham's plan was to frame someone else and then kill that person himself, citing self-defense. In preparation, he dismissed the 24-hour police guard. For the next stage of his plan, Graham needed to lure one of the possible targets to the farmhouse. By Monday, April 30, Graham had settled. on Colin Bedale Taylor.
他还编造了与科林·比代尔-泰勒的边界纠纷。这些承认开启了多条调查线索，所有这些都将格雷厄姆描绘成某人怨恨的目标。警方认为，格雷厄姆的计划是陷害别人，然后亲手杀死那个人，并以自卫为由。在准备过程中，他解雇了24小时警察守卫。为了计划的下一阶段，格雷厄姆需要将其中一个可能的目标引诱到农舍。到4月30日星期一，格雷厄姆已经选定了
That afternoon, Graham invited Colin over to Whitten Hill, likely under the pretense of doing some furniture restoration work. Police were called to the farm within 10 minutes of Colin leaving his home. Investigators therefore concluded that Graham had opened fire on Colin almost immediately after he set foot inside. Colin was shot twice in the chest. Forensics revealed that the second shot had been fired as Colin was falling backwards or lying flat on the floor, disputing Graham's claim of self-defense.
科林·比代尔-泰勒。那天下午，格雷厄姆邀请科林来到威登山，很可能是以做一些家具修复工作的借口。在科林离开家后10分钟内，警察就被叫到了农场。因此，调查人员得出结论，格雷厄姆在科林踏入室内后几乎立即开火。科林胸部中了两次枪。法医显示，第二枪是在科林向后倒下或平躺在地板上时射出的，这反驳了格雷厄姆关于自卫的说法。
Graham then set about staging the crime scene and making it look like he'd been attacked. The wounds to Graham's face and body were continuous slices, indicating that he was standing very still when the injuries occurred. No defensive cuts were found. on his hands or arms. A forensic expert concluded that Graham's injuries were self-inflicted. After slashing his own face and torso, police believed that Graham lent over Colin's body and placed the Stanley knife in his right hand.
格雷厄姆随后着手布置犯罪现场，使其看起来像是他受到了袭击。格雷厄姆脸部和身体上的伤口是连续的切口，表明他在受伤时站得很稳。他的手或手臂上没有发现防御性伤口。一位法医专家得出结论，格雷厄姆的伤是自残的。在划伤自己的脸和躯干后，警方认为格雷厄姆俯身在科林的尸体上，并将斯坦利美工刀放在他的右手中。
This explained why drops of Graham's blood were found on Colin's body. It also explained why Colin was still holding the knife. Had he really been wielding the knife at Graham, investigators believe, believed Colin would have dropped it after being shot. The round drops of blood on the kitchen floor and the contact blood on the backrest of the chairs indicated that Graham then walked around to the room, upturning the chairs to make it look like a struggle had taken place. Only when Graham was satisfied with the scene did he hit the panic button and wait for the police. Twelve days after the shooting and almost five weeks after the car bomb, Graham Backhouse joined his family in the
这解释了为什么在科林的尸体上发现了格雷厄姆的血滴。这也解释了为什么科林还握着刀。调查人员认为，如果他真的拿着刀对着格雷厄姆，科林在被枪击后会掉落它。厨房地板上的圆形血滴和椅子靠背上的接触血迹表明，格雷厄姆随后在房间里走动，翻倒椅子，使其看起来像是发生过搏斗。只有当格雷厄姆对现场感到满意时，他才按下紧急按钮并等待警察。枪击事件发生12天后，汽车炸弹爆炸近5周后，格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯与家人在
Midlands for the day. When he returned home to Witten Hill that evening, detectives paid him a visit. Graham Backhouse was arrested and charged with the murder of Colomberdale Taylor and the attempted murder of Margaret Backhouse. He was held in remand awaiting trial. Shortly after, prison guards confiscated a letter addressed to local newspaper the Bristol Evening Post as it was being smuggled out of the prison. penned by an anonymous writer, the letter read in part. Them three letters in the Backhouse bomb case, I wrote them. Colin Bidale Taylor made me. He said it was God's work because Backhouse was a wicked man.
米德兰兹度过了一天。那天晚上他回到威登山时，侦探们拜访了他。格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯被捕，并被控谋杀科林·比代尔-泰勒和企图谋杀玛格丽特·巴克豪斯。他被还押候审。不久之后，监狱看守没收了一封写给当地报纸《布里斯托尔晚报》的信，当时它正被偷运出监狱。这封信由一名匿名作者撰写，部分内容如下：“巴克豪斯炸弹案中的那三封信，是我写的。科林·比代尔-泰勒逼我写的。他说这是上帝的工作，因为巴克豪斯是个邪恶的人。”
Colin never said anything about any bomb until afterwards. I would not have done it if he had said. I told Colin that God would punish him, and now he is dead. God has forgiven me. I don't trust pigs. That is why I write to you. Please help. Police knew immediately who wrote the letter.
“科林直到事后才提到任何炸弹。如果他说了，我不会做的。我告诉科林上帝会惩罚他，现在他死了。上帝原谅了我。我不信任猪。这就是我写信给你的原因。请帮忙。”警方立刻知道是谁写的这封信。
A few days earlier, Graham Backhouse had written to his wife Margaret, claiming that the police had framed him. He was desperate to, quote, Get out of this hellhole. Graham revealed his plan to write an anonymous letter to a newspaper to make people believe that, someone else was responsible for the bomb. Graham boasted that he could write the letter well enough to throw the police case into confusion. He just needed Margaret to send him more writing materials.
几天前，格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯写信给他的妻子玛格丽特，声称警察陷害了他。他绝望地想“逃离这个地狱”。格雷厄姆透露了他的计划，即写一封匿名信给报纸，让人们相信“其他人对炸弹负责”。格雷厄姆吹嘘说他能把信写得足够好，足以让警方的案件陷入混乱。他只需要玛格丽特给他寄更多的书写材料。
Graham concluded, I know it is wrong of me to ask you to do this, but I am innocent. I have no one else to turn to. You are my only hope. I love you. Margaret didn't follow through on Graham's request. Instead, she handed the letter to the police. The handwriting on the Bristol Evening Post letter was analysed by an expert, leaving no doubt that it had been written by Graham Backhouse. Graham's trial commenced in January 1985. He pleaded not guilty to both charges and testified to his innocence on the stand. The prosecutor told the court that Graham Backhouse intended to kill his wife Margaret in order to pay
格雷厄姆总结道：我知道要求你这样做是错的，但我确实是无辜的。我已走投无路，你是我唯一的希望。我爱你。玛格丽特没有照格雷厄姆的要求去做，而是把信交给了警方。《布里斯托尔晚报》那封信上的笔迹经专家鉴定，毫无疑问是格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯所写。格雷厄姆的审判于1985年1月开始。他对两项指控均表示不认罪，并在证人席上坚称自己无辜。检察官告诉法庭，格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯企图杀害他的妻子玛格丽特，以便用她的人寿保险金偿还
his debts with her life insurance money. He said that Graham's crimes were carefully planned, quite deliberate, and carried out in cold blood. Margaret Backhouse sobbed quietly in the public gallery each day as the evidence against her husband was laid out. Graham denied this version of events. He maintained his story about being ambushed by Columba Dale Taylor, saying he'd feared for his life during the attack.
他的债务。他说，格雷厄姆的罪行是经过精心策划、蓄意为之，且冷血实施的。玛格丽特·巴克豪斯每天在旁听席上听着针对她丈夫的证据陈述时，都会默默啜泣。格雷厄姆否认了这一说法。他坚持自己关于遭到科伦巴·戴尔·泰勒伏击的说法，称他在袭击中曾担心自己的生命安全。
In his closing statement, the prosecutor told the jury that they simply needed to decide who was the villain in the case. Was it Colin Bedale Taylor or Graham Backhouse? When the jury was unable to reach a unanimous decision, the judge permitted a majority verdict. 90 minutes later, with a majority of 10 to 2, the jury found Graham Backhouse guilty on both counts. Graham began shaking in the dock as he was given two life sentences. The judge concluded, You are a devious and wicked man. The enormity of the crime that you have committed is very grave.
在结案陈词中，检察官告诉陪审团，他们只需要决定谁是此案中的恶棍。是科林·比代尔·泰勒还是格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯？当陪审团无法达成一致裁决时，法官允许了多数裁决。90分钟后，陪审团以10比2的多数票裁定格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯两项罪名成立。当被判处两项终身监禁时，格雷厄姆在被告席上开始颤抖。法官总结道：你是一个阴险邪恶的人。你所犯下的罪行极其严重。
Not content with trying to kill a wife who, according to your own evidence, loved you and had done you no wrong. You then set about cold-bloodedly to plot and kill your neighbour who had never done you. you any harm and whom you barely knew. Outside court, Horton locals spoke of their relief at the verdict. One woman told reporters, there has been a cloud hanging over us since the car bomb, but now we hope the village can get back to normal. Gillian Lipiat, the woman Graham, claimed to be having an ongoing affair with, said, Backhouse goes down as another liar. He is a lot of. He is a not said one word of truth in court. Margaret Backhouse requested privacy for herself and her family. Despite the trauma that the farmhouse represented, Margaret and her children continued to live at Widenhill
不仅试图杀害一个根据你自己的证词显示深爱你且从未做过对不起你的事的妻子，你随后还冷血地策划杀害了从未伤害过你、你几乎不认识的邻居。庭外，霍顿当地居民表达了对判决的宽慰。一位女士告诉记者，自从汽车炸弹事件以来，我们一直笼罩在阴云之下，但现在我们希望村子能恢复正常。格雷厄姆声称与之有婚外情的吉莉安·利皮亚特说，巴克豪斯是个彻头彻尾的骗子。他在法庭上没说一句真话。玛格丽特·巴克豪斯要求为她和家人保留隐私。尽管农舍承载着创伤，玛格丽特和她的孩子们仍继续住在怀登希尔
until it was sold six months later. The property eventually became a horse boarding stable and riding estate. Supported by the community, Margaret remained close to Horton. The following year, her divorce from Graham was finalised, with the court readily agreeing with the grounds of unreasonable behaviour. In 1994, less than 10 years into his sentence, Graham Backhouse was playing cricket in the prison exercise yard when he suffered a heart attack. He died three days later. The following year, 48-year-old Margaret Backhouse passed away from cancer. She was survived by her two teenage children. Colin Bedale Taylor had been a man of the people. In addition to his furniture restoration work, he had served as a chairman on the village hall committee and had helped draw plans
直到六个月后房子被卖掉。该房产最终变成了一个马匹寄养马厩和骑马庄园。在社区的支持下，玛格丽特一直住在霍顿附近。次年，她与格雷厄姆的离婚手续办妥，法院欣然同意了以行为不当为由的离婚申请。1994年，在服刑不到10年后，格雷厄姆·巴克豪斯在监狱操场打板球时突发心脏病。三天后他去世了。次年，48岁的玛格丽特·巴克豪斯因癌症去世。她留下了两个十几岁的孩子。科林·比代尔·泰勒曾是一个深受爱戴的人。除了家具修复工作外，他还担任过村公所委员会主席，并帮助制定了
to rebuild the community hall. Just the day before he was killed, Colin had agreed to become a sidesman at the village church, a role that would entail handing out hymn books and showing people to their seats. That same day, he had erected a handmade wooden sign outside the local school, which was facing budget cuts, so that its name could be proudly displayed. The church rector described Colin as a quiet man who was full of fun. In the wake of Graham's conviction, he expressed relief that Colin's name had been completely cleared. Another villager told the Western Daily press. Colin was a good friend to a lot of people and had done many kindnesses.
重建社区大厅的计划。就在他遇害的前一天，科林同意担任村教堂的助手，负责分发赞美诗集并引导人们入座。同一天，他在当地学校外竖起了一个手工制作的木牌，因为学校面临预算削减，他希望学校的名字能被自豪地展示出来。教堂牧师形容科林是一个安静且充满乐趣的人。在格雷厄姆被定罪后，他表示很高兴科林的名誉得到了彻底恢复。另一位村民告诉《西部日报》，科林是许多人的好朋友，做过许多善事。
He will be tremendously missed by the whole village. Six weeks after Colin's murder, nearly every resident of Horton crammed into the small village church to attend his funeral. Referring to the large number of attendees, one local said, The people of Horton will say with their feet what they cannot say with their mouths about the death of Colin. Colin was laid to rest next to his beloved son, Digby. In the weeks that followed, plans were made to erect a plaque in Colin's honour. A community spokesperson told the Bristol Evening Post, We don't want to remember him as a murdered man, but as someone who has done a lot
整个村庄都会无比怀念他。科林遇害六周后，霍顿几乎所有的居民都挤进了村里的小教堂参加他的葬礼。提到众多出席者，一位当地人说，霍顿人民将用他们的行动来表达他们无法用言语表达的对科林离世的哀思。科林被安葬在他心爱的儿子迪格比身边。在随后的几周里，人们计划为科林立一块牌匾以示纪念。一位社区发言人告诉《布里斯托尔晚报》，我们不想记住他是一个被谋杀的人，而是记住他多年来为村里所做的许多
of work in the village for years. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
工作。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。